you have a very dangerous situation
where people are getting shot where you
got to get out of the way of the
ambulance
then you've got a bunch of absolute
degenerates dancing and jumping and
climbing on a car nothing happens no
consequences whatsoever
i never want to hear about police
brutality again
a lot of violence in our streets there
was a lot of violence
on juneteenth our most sacred national
feast day
juneteenth you know as of uh about eight
minutes ago new juneteenth is
the national independence day that's
actually the name of the act
the juneteenth national independence day
act
so the left contrives this holiday out
of some local tradition in galveston
they invent this whole new national
holiday and there is violence
at juneteenth celebrations
juneteenth partiers shot up a
celebration in
oakland but that wasn't even the
craziest part yet about 5 000 people
gathered at lake merrit in oakland
california to celebrate
juneteenth and seven people get shot
at this celebration gosh sure got rowdy
then an ambulance shows up
and the feast goers started twerking on
the ambulance
you can see when they're trying to like
wheel people into this ambulance
and there's a there's a young woman of
multiple young women
yeah there we go twerking on men on the
ambulance see everyone filming it
probably making it pretty tough to put
the injured people into the ambulance
filming laughing then some guy just
jumps up climbs on top of the ambulance
yeah he's throwing a football that looks
fun
football they're trying to like be nice
maybe you know when i see an ambulance
behind me in traffic i usually pull to
the shoulder of the road
because i want to make sure that i don't
want to impede the ambulance's journey
but uh these guys that didn't didn't
want the ambulance to impede their
ability to grind on one another
and and dance on a car and throw
a football i mention this
not only because i think the juneteenth
national holiday is a farce and a very
bad idea
but also because i never want to hear
about police brutality again
okay i never want to hear about
over-incarceration
and all these and you know the white
supremacist
law enforcement you saw this the other
day actually there were people twerking
on a cop car
in where was it chicago or new york and
the car kept driving like get off the
car
stop it but they're not really doing
anything about it
you you have a very dangerous situation
where people are getting
shot where people need to be taken back
to the hospital where you got to get out
of the way of the ambulance then you've
got a bunch of absolute degenerates
dancing and jumping and climbing on a
car nothing happens no consequences
whatsoever
you've got crime spiking right now in
cities around the country notably
chicago where shootings and murders are
up 50 percent
and what happens no one does they all
complain about police brutality on the
left
they all complain about the
over-incarceration
we have a severe under-incarceration
problem in this country
but just by definition if crime is
spiking if criminals are running free on
the street
then we are under incarcerating people
we need criminal justice reform
to put more criminals in prison it's not
going to happen though
blm rioters are getting completely off
the hook i mean
we talked about it either yesterday or
the previous episode on this show
in the bronx the majority of blm
terrorists are just they're just having
the cases dismissed
the looters the rioters just doesn't
matter now if you go and dance on nancy
pelosi's desk
in a horn helmet then you're gonna get
the book thrown at you you're probably
gonna go to gitmo
but if you shoot up parties if you dance
on ambulances and cop cars
if you riot in city after city after
city and you loot stores
totally fine is that does that seem fair
to you
does that seem like the sort of
civilized society where everyone's
playing by the rules and we can engage
in the free marketplace of ideas
i'm not so sure about that never wrestle
with a
pig that's the title of the whole
episode i'm glad you liked that clip but
you can watch the entire episode right
here on youtube
subscribe ring the bell you'll get the
notifications you can get it at the
michael knowles show audio podcast on
apple podcast google play stitcher
spotify all those places
and you can order my brand new book just
released yesterday
speechless controlling words controlling
minds see you next time
[Music]
you